Let's stay in Texas a little bit and go to Rick
from southeast Texas. Rick from southeast Texas.
What? Just it's a Texas sort of day. You know,
Rick. Rick, welcome. Rick you have self muted.
You can unmute yourself and then you'll be able
to talk to me. Oh, boy. Rick. You there, buddy?
Speaker 2: Do you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Hey, sorry about that, David. Hey. So
I really wanted to call in about something more.
More meta. Perhaps the oranges. Oranges of your
show. So I was wondering, you know, with with your
show, you mean a one man show, and respectfully,
you. That's where you should be. But have you ever
thought about, like other channels incorporating
other people into your show? Not saying shit, but
I thought or. Or, you know, something like that. I
really want to see your program, you know, explode
and. And grow, so. What are your thoughts on that?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen, every program is
different and sometimes people will write to me
and they'll say, you know, David, your program
would be better if you had an ensemble cast where
you had a whole bunch of people behind a desk or
whatever. You know, your show would be better if
you didn't take calls or if it was all calls or if
you did no interviews or all interviews. The thing
about it is, every show is where it is because of
the way that it has been produced. And I am always
very skeptical of saying if I make this show more
like another show, it will do better, because
maybe that's not the way this show is supposed
to be. So the way we produce the show, it sort
of makes the most sense. The way we're doing
it right now and the way that I do, the sort of
ensemble thing is I'll appear on other shows like
next month, I'll be on the Patrick Bett David Show
down in Florida or might be in Florida. Actually,
I forget where they filmed and I've got some other
appearances coming up. So that's the way I sample
different formats. Rather than like changing what
we do, it's by appearing on other shows that kind
of do it differently, if that makes sense.
Speaker 2: Absolutely no, I agree. And I
think that's what makes her feel a little
bit more more specialized is, you know,
you kind of really get to know you. And and
we hope that we get to see more from you soon.
I'm I'm I'm a Florida Florida whatever you
say. Transplant. So I really hope you enjoy
the sun down there. David, I'm.
Speaker 1: Looking forward to
hopefully good weather. Absolutely.
Speaker 2: Of course. Thank you so
much. Have a wonderful day. All right.
Speaker 1: There is Rick from southeast
Texas. Very, very powerful declaration
and questions, all of which we love.